[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting I'm speaking in a lower
register because I'm sick man I feel
like I should have a mask on I got a
question I think you should too dude I
mean I'm trapped in a small room with
you but it's not the bubonic plague it's
just a cold but I mean might as well be
man I don't want to call it
colds are horrible I had to lay out this
morning you witness by the Sun lady
yeah I had to lay out of work man you
didn't notice me Missy oh you know what
I got so much done so I just came in
here it's trying to figure that out just
to do this today we're gonna be talking
about what's the question man it's not a
good sign for me should the malady my
voice is sounding low and my brain is is
not on go well going to deep-sea Drive
should the 90s come back should the 90s
come back Lando gave me this cold man
and I'm like I got home last night I'm
like I feel like just straight-up
Dookie mm-hmm never got a cold they must
have cohorted who got it from who is he
better I got it from Lando isletas Lando
better
I said Lando how long did it take you to
get over your cold cuz he is better he
was like two days to two and a half days
really like he's my doctor Shepard still
has it so keppard Lando is frequently
cold he gets caught all the time he's a
viral dude but Lando gave Shepard
catches everything but if he's getting
over at Lando gave it a shepherd so
Lando is patient zero well I think you
know I the cold originated with him this
in a weird way at least parallels our
conversation today because I think trend
spread viruses well no okay that but
also our kids you I start to observe
thing about observe things about fashion
choices entertainment choices life
choices that my kids are making and I'm
like scratching my head and I'm realize
man the 90s are coming back they may
already be back hold on do you see is
that a good idea
how do we feel about it I lived it
brother I lived it boy listen to me bo I
lived it both and until I talked when I
was living it and you you also taught it
you were telling me that you thought you
taught that the Shepherd right I know so
my nephews who still live in North
Carolina who do not sound like rednecks
at all do have friends who do sound like
rednecks and apparently still use the
word Bo because they regularly go into
these accents where they used to turn Bo
and so he hung out with mine we should
clarify what Bo is it's just a
all-encompassing term for just another
dude a friend yeah like a friendly male
acquaintance yeah it's like dude it's
like dude and it's like bro in fact like
the West Coast surfer Shepherd says it's
snacky so often that I told you this I
haven't told listen like grade school
stuff for us to call each other Bo
so we went I went to a couple weeks ago
like when Shepherd was starting school I
went to this like orientation thing in
his classroom classroom you've already
given me the cold look at my throat is
already closing it happened this is
psychosomatic yes of course
yeah it's you of course it is I'm just
you're too close to me to speak that way
it's speaking away that doesn't propel a
lot out of your mouth speaking of quiet
way like that way just if you could just
just kind of keep the germs oh gosh it
backfired if you want to hear more of
that bit all you need to do is watch the
episode of good mythical morning where
you got the but I got the B beard you
can talk to the bees nothing wrong with
that the only thing is they don't like
the carbon dioxide in your breath talk
without using air that's tough Rob
it's you sound weird but that's my
that's my favorite part of that video
they're backwards talking it's not even
gonna do it the improvisational
backwards speaking because we just got
such a kick out of that because we
didn't know we had never done it it was
an aha moment of pure invention
unadulterated discovery so Shepard but I
am gonna do it the rest you're gonna
make yourself sick sicker man you're
sucking in more stuff from the work from
the world I could be in I could be in
the next Marvel movie is like a villain
I mean I know you auditioned for one if
anything is you have to kind of explain
the cool thing about that is I'm sucking
in the whole time I know that it may not
be so evident to you when you listen to
me I don't think that that helps any
sort of audition no no to have to
explain if you get close you can
actually feel the biology of the
negative pressure of my voice okay so
I'm still on a tangent about Shepard so
you can't go on another tangent within
the tangent cuz we got to get back to
the night cuz we have a whole list of
things from the 90s that we're gonna
decide individually if they should be
brought back can I disagree I'm not
going to continue without finishing this
story - so he wrote this thing he was
supposed to fill out this thing that he
like writes a note to the parents and
when the parents come to the orientation
that he was not present for you can like
sit down at his desk and read this thing
that he wrote the parents okay being the
parents mm-hmm and in in it in this
little blank sheet of paper it said hey
mom and dad hey mom and dad bow how do
you spell it
vo he was like Bo I don't know what
we're supposed to be doing right now Bo
but it kind of seems like a waste of
time to me Bo but Bo just as long as you
read this boat and he just went on and
on and just kept using Bo and then he
called himself ship Bo as as like his
sign off it sounds like something we
would have written in each other's year
exactly I was like this is so
reminiscent of the way that that we
would have decided to do something and I
never really I didn't send that stuff to
my parents I wanted to never I would
never cut up like that one my parent but
it's not mine different generation man
my comedy night back was totally secret
from my family but well for the most
part they would get reports from like
principals and other people in authority
yeah I mean we had a lot we had a good
time in my family but I couldn't call my
dad bow know it wouldn't worked Bono
that is a 90s thing bo Jackson I had I
did I did have those those
cross-trainers are both yeah you have
them no crap I totally forgot Yuri
bought those I'm contributing to the
resurgence of the 90s why I think we'll
need to get into that in a little bit
but where do you want to start well I've
known that it's been happy
I know I've known that it's going to
happen and I've seen little you know
pieces of evidence here in there that
it's happening you can tell by the tone
of my voice that I'm not super excited
about this we'll get into the psychology
of that but the moment that really hit
home for me was about a year ago I am
wearing a hoodie a hoodie that you have
seen if you have watched many episodes a
good mythical morning it is it is a navy
hoodie that I have it's like a
tight-fitting hoodie from the company
publish and okay whatever and it's like
a cool a cool brand okay and and I have
worn it a bunch will probably shoot you
will we can cut if you're if you're
watching will cut to a picture of it
right now
here it is I've been anyway I've always
thought you look pretty good in that
hoodie Rhett as I step outside of myself
and observed myself and that's why I've
worn it often so I come downstairs with
this hoodie on and a lot kind of looks
at me and Snickers now I've worn the
city in his presence before but you got
a
he's you know he's 14 now he's a
freshman in high seas he's in the big
league he's becoming a man and he's like
dad why is your hoodie so tight and I
happen to notice that as he said this he
was wearing a hoodie Oh
in his hoodie in sharp contrast was not
tight was not tight at all in fact I
don't believe that any part of the
hoodie was actually in contact with his
body whereas whereas my hoodie was in
full contact with every part of me
you're saying that his hoodie operate
overing like a bounce house like he's
got its got like a blow or hooked up to
the back end it was more like it was
being magnetically like repulsed from
his boat talking like a monorail system
here yeah but I mean kind of like a
bounce house and inflated I guess it was
it must have been touching him in
certain places like the shoulders it has
to drape from something but if you could
see like points of contact what was your
bird
I was like this this head he's cool man
[Laughter]
and in that moment I realized you've
lost I was wrong
I knew I was wrong I was like as I was
saying that I was like oh I've become I
had become a dad and I and I am a dad
have been a dad for quite some time it's
funny that you've had children for 13
years a moment I became at that's when I
knew I was a dad
14 years in at 14 but because because I
I assume that you think the same way we
tend to think of ourselves as being
somewhat impervious to becoming the debt
like you know I mean III because we do
what we do for a living
we end up we dress in ways that are more
I don't use the term boyish but I could
say more youthful trendy then maybe
other dads that are are you know our
kids friends dads our our sense of style
is not defined it still is still
something to
we define it's not something that a lot
of people when they get to be dad age or
whatever they've moved on in their life
they're wearing the clothes that they
have for the most part and it's not
about style anymore
it's not about style or they're not on
the street man they're not they're not
hopping down the street they're in a
cubicle or some other legitimate
environment right we are not in they go
straight from their homes to the cubicle
and never get on the street at all right
they teleport they teleport directly to
the cubicles like I like to picture us
on still on the street sure we're 40 mm
but we're out not for long we're out
trotting around on the street I see like
hopscotch on the street and I'm like I'm
gonna take a second and do this
hopscotch yeah that's how I see myself
I'm a Josh Street stuff I'm a guy who'll
just get into Street stuff like hopping
on one leg in public hopscotch when was
the last time you saw hopscotch
hopscotch hopscotch on the sidewalk or
like it doesn't happen in this town or
like if a hydrant okay I like I'm gonna
go for if I'm gonna go for a swim I'm
nervous I'm gonna go for an impromptu
I've never seen but I'd like to think of
myself as that type of vibe man
yeah I'm I'm a 40 year old trapped in
just too much like a streetwalker man
but have you not also saw that term but
yeah yeah I I just decided to move
beyond it I'm a street swimmer street
swimmer hopscotch Oh have you not also
thought a trendy daddy that you that at
some point you can't keep holding on to
this thread do you know what I'm saying
like at some point you're gonna have to
quit trying to be relevant and then you
go into some sort of now I'm old man
cool there's a transition and when he
said that thing about my hoodie I was
like is this the first signal that I
need to begin transitioning into just
old man cool so oh no no you need to try
harder man that's my third I know but at
some point it becomes it could
ridiculous well and I believe that I but
for me I believe that the next 10 years
of my life my 40s will be it when I'm 50
I'm gonna be like Jeff Goldblum you you
just wait what I'm 50
he's still incredibly cool but he's not
trendy he's not he wouldn't he wouldn't
wear a cheek tracksuit he's not gonna
wear a Gucci dress I don't know and I
don't think you would we don't know I
don't think he would wear a hoodie at
all I think he would wear for comedic
effect and we might very well do that
too I totally relate to this last night
I was actually wearing this shirt listen
I'm gonna admit it I put I left the
office yesterday and for some admitted
confluence of circumstances I changed my
shirt right before I left to get off my
back and I put this one on I get home I
get in my pajamas cuz I feel like crap
mm-hmm and then I get up this morning
I'm like you got to put on something
else put this shirt back on cuz I've
only worn it for literally two and I'm
gonna be sick longer you put on a sick
cert oh gosh how bad I don't know if
that science but it's so comfortable I
will describe this shirt it is a gray
sweatshirt with nothing printed on it
and lo and behold no sleeves well no
there are sleeve you it has short
sleeves depends on your definition of it
has sleeves that go to my bicep and then
it's fringed as if it has been modified
mm-hmm
it was cut but cut by a machine you know
what I'm saying and on purpose as of I
mean two weeks ago and never would have
worn this shirt I have what what has
happened in the past two weeks okay you
got sick
well I'm Daniel bought this shirt for me
right you know Daniel buys some clothes
for us like here's the thing I you hate
we both hate shopping so badly mm-hmm
that Here I am stepping into something
that I thought I didn't want to talk
about that yeah I got we got people who
buy clothes for us sometimes not all of
our clothes but all right it's it
happens and he like rolls in with his
shirt and I'm like I just can't I cannot
go into a probably place in trying to it
try on stuff because you're not that
anybody cares but I'm just too big of a
douche for that I hate it so bad I would
wear
I've got this I've got this tension in
my life well I'm gonna get to the
tension later for now I just want to say
that easer I got this shirt I'm wearing
it last night I have to take Lincoln to
sign up for his basketball league and
we're walking in and I'm like he gets
out of the car first he's walking ahead
of me and I'm thinking about this shirt
pretty self-conscious and I I'm like
Lincoln he turns around I'm like what
are you what do you think of my shirt oh
you okay you asked him walked right into
it
and he was like I could tell he was
assessing how tight it was or if it said
champion anywhere on it and you know the
the indications of coolness in his mind
I guess and he said it's cool turn
around we kept walking I was like
alright okay you know I felt the eggs
I felt the opposite of you because he
could have said it's cool but it it
doesn't work for you you're too dad
but he didn't say that so I do feel like
our kids are certainly a catalyst in us
considering this thing that is happening
well I will say that I am surprised so I
never would have worn so here's how I
would evaluate your approach also Stevie
said she liked she said that's a good
shirt and she knows what's cool I mean
she you know so here he's a beacon of
business how I I've kind of understood
your fashion instincts you would be the
one who would be would more readily
embrace a trend so like as pants
continue to get skinnier and skinnier
you went to the skinny jeans before I
did however there are yeah there's a
certain number of things in which you
draw a very stark line mm-hmm and I
would have guessed that this would have
been in one of the places that you drew
a line this because it's like but but I
think it's happening in this I'm again
I'm just evaluating as a outside
observer is that you know that the
things that you have enjoyed in the
trends that you've embraced which kind
of represent more of the 80s which is
the tighter
stuff mm-hmm that's not a sustainable
thing just like my hoodie it has to
reduce there's a contraction release
there reduces and is it is the correct
term though because it got tight and not
needs to be loose expansion and
contraction you know and and so I think
that this is expanding the hoodies are
expanding yeah and you're doing
something that's uncomfortable because I
would never wear that shirt that mark I
saw markiplier wear like wearing like a
few weeks ago it was a sweatshirt
it was sleeveless but they they cut off
the sleeves but they didn't cut off the
hood yeah it was a it was like Leila's
hoodie that's where I'm now drawing the
line I can have half a sleeve no hood
but I can't have a hood and no sleep at
all is that is that trendy or is that
just nothing markiplier just did I don't
feel equipped to make that it's out
there he didn't he didn't make that
sweatshirt he didn't alter one I don't
know it's pretty easy to make one I'm
gonna do is cut the sleeves off the
hoodie requires scissors yeah I don't
think he's allowed ok so we're gonna get
in Marky Mark did that you feel like I'm
sure the Marky Mark would have but again
Marky Mark he is no longer it's Mark
Wahlberg yeah he's a he's a he's a
different person
ok so we're gonna get into that we're
gonna talk a little bit about the
psychology of trends and how they come
back and in in the life cycle of trends
and then we're actually gonna be like
links that go through some things that
are of the 90s that some of them may be
back some of may be coming back and our
unadulterated opinions about those
things but first we want to let you know
that you can not grab that amazing
sweatshirt that link is wearing maybe
one day we'll have one of those in stock
which you can grab this my t-shirt what
does this a be your mythical best be
your mythical best it is patterned after
the button your fly campaign the 1990s
Oh
Levi's button your fly campaign we did
that with permission right no we didn't
what we don't have to so it is for this
pick
they're in and this is again we've done
a few of these like we've got some 90s
throwback friends T I mean the Chili
Peppers t I don't it's it's certainly
from the 90s but I don't consider it a
it's not necessarily 90s design but yeah
it well it it I mean it I guess it
technically is go to mythical dot store
if you're into that or if you're not we
have lots of other stuff for those of
you who are not prepared to go full 90s
I don't know if we showed our hand by
selling merch that is 90s inspired but I
don't think we did we're trying to get
ahead we're trying to get ahead of
things yeah I don't know thank you for
supporting it judge it for yourself okay
now what would you have said so there's
some articles that talked about the
lifecycle of a trend and the resurgence
of a trend what would you just before
having looked at any of this information
what would you have said how long it
takes for something to come back well
when we were in college like freshman
year of college for us
there's 97 thanks we were nice ignite
service yeah we were into like vintage
goes from the 70s bell-bottom so that's
that's 20 I mean that's about 20 years
actually so I think that's how that's
how I feel that's how I relate to what's
happening is we all I got my nanny to
alter my pants to look like bell-bottoms
now we were in a band he altered my
pants to look like and she altered yours
because well when you're in a when
you're in a band you just have all the
one of my favorite parts about being in
the band was the freedom associated with
a fashion expression you didn't have to
explain yourself yeah yeah you've got
bleached hair you've got bell bottom on
slide this is what I'm a performer wax
paper dogs with a Z you ever heard of
this I'm not just a student I'm a
performer right
hello I'm not just a normal person I
couldn't do this if I was so we would go
to the thrift store and again I don't
think we went to the thrift first we
went to the store looking for those
things but it also so
happened that those things were there we
would also buy collar you know and that
that doesn't necessarily have to line up
we could say we want it we thought it'd
be cool to be in the 70s but people have
returned crap 20 years later they
finally were cleaning out their their
house or their parents house or however
it works and I actually got a lot of
stuff from my papa's closet like
sweaters and stuff like that
so it was a little nebulous but it was
it's nothing you could get off a rack
that's centered on the 70s so to answer
your question you were to sit about 20
years just I would have said that yeah
well I actually think that most of most
of the opinion out there is that it's
it's it's between 20 and 30 and actually
kind of pushing into 30 and I actually
believe that that still is true if you
think about when it was cool to for us
to work and again people didn't we were
wearing like the ridiculous bell-bottoms
but like people were wearing like
bootcut jeans was sort of the the way
that the the trend of bell-bottoms came
back into jeans in the late 90s and
early 2000s was bootcut it wasn't
bell-bottoms necessarily I mean my wife
had some like legitimate bell-bottoms
but everybody had bootcut jeans who do
everybody who has anybody had bootcut
jeans right but that was actually like
bell-bottoms were kind of they were
starting to come in in the late 60s
right early 70s so you can argue with
phasing out so and actually so in this
this article from a place from a website
the patterning calm and heard of that
before my guy named Patrick Metzger he
thought he calls it the 30-year cycle
mm-hm and I want to not just talk about
clothes but talking about media and
specifically film remakes but he thinks
it takes about 30 years for a critical
mass of consumers like when you're young
and you're a consumer of culture to then
become the creator of the products that
are being consumed and so on average it
takes about between 20 and 30 years for
the critical mass to build so that
you're beginning to put the stuff out
there you're in charge
what people are actually wearing and
you're dining it you're taking you're
writing that screenplay you're taking
cues from your childhood your childhood
in your experience which kind of helps
to explain okay it kind of helps to
explain stranger things is if you want
to talk about something that is you know
incredibly successful show that
everybody knows about that you've is
very rare to find somebody who says I
didn't like stranger things like most
everybody enjoyed it to some degree I
have to assume that the duffer brothers
the creators of stranger things were as
kids watched ET and everything else that
was referenced and well okay so this is
according to this guy Patrick this is a
list of things sort of referenced and
pulled on and put on screen and stranger
things like there's weather alerts
because I'm sorry to admit I from reason
I didn't I'm not caught up on season two
no no no I'm not gonna talk about
anything specific to strangers the whole
family watched it in two days and I
missed it but this is just a list and
I'm gonna and the time frame is actually
gonna go from 42 years to 30 years but
okay so Dungeons & Dragons tabletop game
which came out in 74 that's 42 years ago
it's still ubiquitous but it actually
reached you know popularity in the late
70s early 80s so it's really closer to
30 years close these are just different
movies and you can do we're not going to
go into analyzing this Close Encounters
of the Third Kind 77 alien 79 ETA T to
the thing 82 poltergeist 82 firestarter
84 Nightmare on Elm Street 84 explorers
85 I'm sorry I don't know what explorers
is easy thing oh okay
The Goonies 85 and stand by me 80s I
love Ethan Hawke man I'd go back and
watch that just because I love that they
put a spaceship in their backyard they
got out of space so these and they all
die yeah so I don't know so the duffer
brothers are enjoying all this stuff
obviously and now they're in a position
to say hey I can I can write something
and it the fascinating thing is that
way that our kids enjoyed stranger
things without knowing any of the
references you know it's I think that's
the testimony to how well made it was
that it you don't have to know those
things you don't have to be you know 40
however old they are and again that's
the 80s but it's also happening but
we're it with the 90s we are in the
transition right i we're it's it's you
know it's there's no science to this
there's all kinds of reasons why did
they happen but we're kind of in that
point where and I think about the way
that I think about it as I'm kind of a
child of the 80s and the 90s because
that my childhood and like adolescence
sort of comprises the 80s and 90s so
when I think about the 80s in the 80s
fashion in the pieces of 80s fashion
that I've kind of embraced the easiest
thing that was kind of an extreme thing
that I would have never anticipated 12
13 years ago skinny jeans right we've
already talked about it yeah but I mean
mean t-shirts and like a Members Only
jacket like I owned a Members Only
jacket since since college I bought the
one that I still have that baby blue
jacket at that thrift store the one
thrift store behind the Bojangles that
we'd always go to you remember Alan we
got everything from that one thrift
store well and well the reason I use
that and Gil you're right about the the
jacket but I I'm I'm specifically kind
of zeroing in on the skinny jeans
because it's such a its first of all
it's still kind of polarizing there are
people who definitely did not come along
with us on along that and we even to
this day we still get people making fun
of us wearing skinny jeans it's good
it's a little old at this point but I
don't do it I mean you still so many
more
you don't wear I wear these joggers man
just for comfort
well yeah but I guess I the jeans that I
do what if you didn't have to work they
would still be on the skinnier side but
they were not the women's jeans that I
wore in college you got me yeah wheat
like by senior year in college got to
some places where it was basically like
leggings right yeah but those are
beginning to a lot of
security in that they're beginning to
expand in a nobody nobody at like our
kids school what kid would come to
school in skinny jeans right now but
they're not wearing they can wear big
pants but what they're wearing are these
warmups yeah they're wearing sports
clothing they're wearing warm-up pants
but then they're like have Gucci's desk
designs on them because I mean there are
Gucci track suits that are you know
$1,500 that then our kids are wearing
the emulated cheaper versions of those
and I'm more power to them because
there's it looks like they're walking
around pajamas but they're so
comfortable yeah and I I'm tempted to
get in on that just because of the just
the comfort zone but that is not why
they're wearing it though it is not it's
just cool and it's it's I mean it's it's
so influenced by hip hop culture which
is the it's pop culture now and you
think about which was kind of the case
in the night and the 90s yeah I mean
well there was there were different
pockets but the way that you would be
inspired from a fashion standpoint was
through music videos and movies mm-hmm
and music videos that happened so much
quicker that it started to dictate what
you would wear and I see what's coming
back even though I mean there was grunge
there was all tight I mean there was all
types of looks but the hip-hop look at
the 90s is the one that's coming back so
strong you've got tracksuits
you've got oversized clothes like the
hoodies you've got name brands like I
don't know I don't I guess I thought of
I don't know if technically champion is
like a was a hip-hop brand in the 90s I
actually never thought of it that way I
don't know if it did become but up but I
feel like there's a weight at room
champion is coming back now it's I mean
it's is it's oversized hoodies and bold
colors things that are very hip-hop my
knees prominent logos
prominent low so that's another thing
that that's coming back is the bigger
and the more obvious more prominent that
the logo is the better and so I mean
like yeah the kids are wearing
sweatpants with with champion written
down the side and there was a point at
which it was like that became taboo it
was like yeah no I don't want to I don't
want to advertise so boldly what what it
is in my body you know yeah hike too
much but you know what I the thing that
I read it was to it mentioned Instagram
culture and how that helps make sense of
these real big logos yeah it's like you
can very quickly in a in a pic or just
just the story moment you can understand
how fashionable some you can see the
logo yeah I mean I remember we were his
Tommy Hilfiger coming back because I
remember I guess did that was the that
was the biggest brand for me when mom
mama would take me to crabtree mall I'd
look for that that Tiger looking logo
and some of those would be huge but
that's how you need you aware and Tommy
hope if shirt said it the shirts will be
crazy yeah they say Tommy Hilfiger all
over it and stuff but yeah I would just
wear like the polo shirt but it would be
a Tommy Hilfiger insignia honor but then
we started wearing those button ups that
were like four panel button up so it
looked like they took for Tommy Hilfiger
shirts that had no business being worn
together they spliced them like a
tic-tac-toe and then they reposition
them so it's very blocky like you
remember that like you'd have plaid on
your left shoulder and then you'd have
like blue denim on your right shoulder
and then it'd be like some green welding
so it right here in it okay again and
back to the the douche the douchiness
yes coming back Daniel who helps us
figure out what we're gonna wear because
we don't want to shop he suggests things
and he put there was a shirt that he put
into my rotation that was a flannel
shirt with denim color
it was denim collar and did him pockets
on a
red flannel shirt or the opposite it was
the toast two things combined exactly
what you're talking about and I was very
uncomfortable putting it on okay I was
like I am not comfortable with this at
all like this is not my style
it's so 90s I hate it and I wore it on
the show and let me tell you y'all ain't
ready for the 90s either because all the
comments were like don't ever wear that
shirt again Rhett oh that is so heinous
but you will wear some really bold
patterns yeah but that's the bold
patterns are an independent stream that
is not really bold blocky colors is very
nice but bold patterns is something that
sort of can find their way into any
particular trend but yeah I like to take
some risks when it comes to patterns I
will in colors too I don't have like a
color palette that I'm like I know you
have certain things you don't cut hose
you don't know where I don't necessarily
have that so I took that chance but then
everybody hated it and then when we were
kind of going through and thinning out
the wardrobe yeah put that in the thin
out pile and then the next thing you
know Jenna he's walking around here
wearing it is that right yeah I almost
was like you didn't ask me but I did
throw it away so what I didn't throw it
away I know but it was understood that
whoever would wanted to wear it could
wear it now yeah we put out a general
slack that said there's a pile of
clothes if you want anybody take it so
like that we actually did say you should
take it and wear it I've seen a number
of my shirts that I called walking
around this office now and I made up my
mind
contrary to my overwhelming desire as
link to point these things out and have
an awkward conversation about the shirt
that you're wearing that was mine I made
it I was like link don't do it don't be
linked good you say that moral these are
these are these are employees these are
teammates don't be linked in this
situation so I'm not I'm not gonna
acknowledge that he might is wearing a
shirt that used to be mine I can't say
that interpret like a professional like
counselor capacity I would say you know
what your new motto should be don't be
linked because I think that it should
probably be be all the link that you can
be there are there there seems to be a
lot of wisdom in that don't be length
motto as it relates to people wearing
clothes like that I on the floor okay
but I feel a sense of regret about
giving that shirt away because when I
wasn't ready
the audience was ready take you back but
I just I'm gonna I'm right now go out
there and she's not wearing it I bet you
can just find it go to her house go
through all the drawers and find it I'm
not gonna be like that's the thing I
understand but before we go through the
these these different trends that may or
may not be coming back I I do honestly
feel like my approach has been okay
there's this train there's a train of
trench rain it's going by and I have
felt this not just because we're in the
business of being in front of people all
the time but also just a sense of pride
and just wanting to seem cool I have
elephant I I have in my life I have
tried to be sensitive to the trends and
kind of is what I'm wearing cool and
trendy you want to be informed by the
trends but not hopelessly chlorine to
seem too legit to quit but I just I want
to ask the question is there a point at
which you quit trying to run along
beside the train is it no I'm too legit
I've actually have actually but it it
has to happen you're saying a lot of
thought in this 80 years old and you're
still gonna be like trying to be trendy
are you gonna like I think at some point
you calcify and you sort of you're on
the train and you jump out with whatever
you've got in your hands at the time you
live the rest of your life with that
Jeff gold whatever you had has not
calcified he has identified with his
inner self he is on a new track fashion
he's on a new track fashion is an
opportunity to express yourself and if
you're I don't want to wear anything I
don't believe in but I want to wear
things that push me to continue to
Express
Who I am yeah but Jenna would not wear
that plaid and denim shirt no but he
wouldn't calcify not making a new choice
he's on a new track what I'm saying is
it different it's a different train for
old people that's not a cool old people
that's all I'm saying
I don't think it's the same trend with
if you're on a train that's got a bunch
of young people on it and you're the
really old guy eventually I mean some
people can do that but make sure they're
like alright dude get only old people
trace it's interesting all right cuz
filter that through what I've decided
okay because I actually think by not
changing I have made it I had a bigger
problem so I do not changing I'd I've
decided what do you mean by a few weeks
ago I decided that I was going to change
my fashion sense I was gonna change a
key part of my wardrobe we didn't talk
about this I decided that I was going to
get rid of the graphic t-shirts well I
should I should say a certain subset of
those the logo slash pop culture
t-shirts I'm done with it I'm done with
the t-shirts that are cute and it's say
something neat just that people will
just comment online I'll say it again a
pop culture reference or something
that's cute give me an example of one of
your shirts that you that people would
recognize that you're no longer wearing
uh I made a big pile of them and I got
rid of them and you can see people
wearing around the office know well some
are just like jokes like there was one
that was like he had a boy on it and he
was exploding something and it said
something about science you actually
wore that on the show at some point and
it was I think I wore it once I didn't
love the colors of it so I didn't wear
it that much but then there was one that
had like Mario Brothers on it even Star
Wars hmm like I don't want to wear
properties like that now bands are
different I'll wear a band
and I'll wear something that's artistic
like a like a cool design that might be
repurposed from something else or it may
be have designed specifically for the
t-shirt but I'm not gonna wear just a
pop culture reference oh look at that
it's and what is in its Han Solo and
what was the reason it has to do with
the 90s
I just think first of all I knew that
you just can't keep wearing the same
things I also thought in a way similar
to me changing my hairstyle at years ago
was that it just cut it just seemed kind
of boyish and cute and I was kind of I
was kind of I got kind of over it hmm
so I think that's what went into it an
assumption that my fashion was gonna
evolve and I had a realization that that
should have happened maybe a year or two
earlier you see you know it's if you're
you see like some some old guys like an
old hippie guy who's wearing like a
Zeppelin t-shirt and you know he's
wearing that shirt because he was he
wore it since he was a Zeppelin fan or
potentially a roadie he kind of looks
like a old washed-up Zeppelin roadie
okay I love him to death but you can
just tell he's wearing that he hasn't
evolved like I just want to continue to
express myself and I think it's even
though I hate shopping
I like expressing myself I like knowing
that I might change my hairstyle again
or I might change what I wear you know
masking my weight line I so I completely
agree with you so I actually like as I
would wear a Zeppelin t-shirt now
because I really like Zeppelin it's a
band but I don't want anything but I
wouldn't want to wear it for you know
for 30 year straight well I think when
so I don't think we're saying something
different but now you are not it's not
contradict or no it's I think it's
unrelated to what you're saying so I'm
saying I still want to I use the term
calcify ingest I'm not saying that I
want to first of all I believe that that
is the wrong move right if so to go
train analogy I feel like the thing that
most people do is they get to a certain
point if they've tried to keep up with
the trends that get to a certain point
then they realize I'm too old for this
I've lost I've lost that sixth sense
that I need to be able to just naturally
do this and I feel like I'm trying too
hard
I'm out and you take all the clothes
that you currently have and you jump out
of the Train and you hit some rocks and
you stand up and you live the rest of
your life
with these clothes you're calcified
right and those people are probably
totally fine and we're not judging those
but I am NOT a proponent or not those
people I'm not talking about
calcification I am talking about
continued innovation just like you're
talking about but I'm saying that at
some point I've got to get off of the
train engine and I'm not I don't want to
necessarily come downstairs and I'm look
like my 14 year old I don't want to come
downstairs and I look like I'm about to
play an NBA basketball game and I'm
actually just going to Walmart do you
know what I'm saying what do you got
under that warmup just underwear yeah
you know I don't want to be that guy all
right you have to wear a uniform under
your warmup right you're exactly right
and so what you're saying yeah but if my
son wants to wear something that looks
like a warm-up and he's just wearing it
because it's cool
I'm that's great I'm not saying I agree
with that I don't want to walk
downstairs and look just like Lincoln
but I I want to be informed by I can be
informed by what's trendy and then land
on what I'm fine with which incidentally
means that I still have sleeves and no
hood yeah okay here's another way to say
it you don't want to look like you're on
a train chasing the current train yeah
that's the worst thing so tight hoodie
apparently is like the caboose of the
train and you got to let the caboose the
caboose and all the people in the
caboose go don't be one of those people
so I'd if I'm gonna wear a hoodie it
needs to look like the kind of hoodie
that's in style not a hoodie that was in
style ten years ago you're gonna start
but I'm but I'm not gonna start wearing
[ __ ] o's like Genco 's haven't come back
and I had with some zinc O's now you're
huge denim pants
giant smokestack pants that like you
know multiple loved ones could crawl up
in one leg of your pant and hide
no no incidentally this year 2018 they
finally went out of business what I was
reading about this at just the moment
when they're about to come back yet they
could have just rolled on in fact that
could have been weeks away the article
that I read said that they had spent the
last 15 years not being profitable every
single year oh really
yeah of course and so there were that
much denim and nobody hears the Colet
hph pair of pants you used to make a
Jenko could it could I mean could could
clone here's what a jean regular gap
size jeans here's what a Jenko exec told
sometimes eventually you can only make
pants so wide that became our Achilles
heel they admitted it they went as big
as they could and then they reached the
end I mean it looked like you were
wearing a skirt and listening to corn
with a k' or with a c' by this point
either one goes pick up a piece of corn
I'll use it like a telephone so I'm not
gonna wit I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna wear [ __ ] O's because even the
joggers like the fact that they give me
this room in the not an ankle I actually
hate the fact that there's no room at
the ankle you try to get them off try to
get them off your legs and then they get
stuck at the ankle yeah I've pulled a
muscle
trying to get my joggers off yeah the
Dockers are incredibly incredibly
comfortable and they're I they're
probably gonna be out of style if
they're not already I don't know the
only reason I don't wear them is because
I can't fight they're supposed to bunch
up at the bottom and that's part of it
they don't bunch up at the bottom
because you're too big it'll like capris
they're like big crotch capris hopefully
they'll come back in pleats pleats are
going to come back they're probably
already in there's probably there's
probably like
famous people wearing pleated suits
right now go through the list man cuz I
want to see what I mean what should come
back what shouldn't in our in our
chasing non chasing the Train opinion
okay well Jenko jeans was the first
thing on the list I know I have other
than the comfort factor it was it at
some point there they weren't
comfortable anymore they would it was
just too much fabric and it was like a
workout just carrying it around and in
the rain oh good god it would be like
they would soak up so much rain and
they're out of business anyway you
couldn't even see that she had on shoes
like I had ginkgos that would cover the
front the front toe of my shoe yes like
why yeah why have any and then it we
need pride in your shoes I would
literally step not only on the back of
the jingoes but I would step on the
front of them and you're walking to
class this is college and like tripping
over your britches [ __ ] it was the shoe
lobby that got that made Jenko go under
right there just covering us up you know
track the money cross colors cross
colors I never wore is very this is a
nineties hip-hop thing very blocky
patterns bold colors again I think going
from 30 to 20 in terms of like the cycle
of things fashion repeating I have to
think that the Internet has accelerated
this along with every single thing else
because you don't just look at the music
videos what you still do but you look at
every you look at their Instagram you
look at what they're wearing today
and then a week from now you can track a
trend so much quicker I think by the way
that's why things are coming back so
much quicker so you don't have to just
watch in living color to start to get an
aesthetic for talking your mom and to
binds a cross color shirt for you well
without a doubt this is this basically
clothing that is informed by hip hop is
going to come back is coming back and
you know I was talking to Locke about
because you know he listens to juice
bought a lot of rap
and he also supplements it with some
other things
he listens to some stuff that we listen
to like as a family whether that be like
Jason Isbell or Sturgill Simpson like
sometimes we'll go and do like Jesse
you'll start playing like 90s indie rock
kind of stuff and but I was asking him I
was like what do you what are your
friends listen to
he's like rap he's like everyone oh yeah
they're all everyone is listening oh
yeah to rap and like almost exclusively
and there's absolutely no doubt that
that's it's just gonna continue to it's
gonna continue to influence their
fashion but if you listen to the first I
actually don't is it
hey more hime how do you say their name
Haim I've listened to him I know what
they sound like I like them but I don't
know how to say in her name but I took I
told Christie I was like listen to the
listen to the the ubiquitous Wilson
Phillips album and then back-to-back
listen to that Haim album not the the
one I think the current one maybe it's a
previous one maybe both
it's the same thing exactly it's amazing
and it's awesome
hmm we put on a Wilson Phillips radio
you know you can say just play anything
that's like of that genre man we brought
up some things that we never thought
we'd listen to again but it's coming
back man
even the Bruno Mars album like the whole
b-side of that is Bill Biv DeVoe yes
yeah yeah I played it for you that day I
was like I can't believe this listen to
it it's like poison poison I mean I mean
the drum machines and the melodies and
everything and he made a bold choice and
I thought it was I thought it was too
much I poo pooed it he's winning all
these Grammies of course who gives
Grammys a bunch of old farts no bucket
hats bucket hats you're talking about
like hip hop like EPA EPMD wore those
all the time they're kind of like Genco
they they had to stop making albums when
they didn't have any more business puns
well I can tell you look back at EPMA
album titles and they're all about
business and then they just ran out I
said well no more business puns we can't
make any more music I'm very particular
about hats and what had some willing to
wear I don't necessarily have a hat face
I don't think I don't think the bucket
hat is gonna do anything for me so for
basically again that's that's way out of
our league
we just can't roll up in a party and
wear him bucket hats and not get laughed
at Reebok pumps I had a pair of these
Alex got a pair of Reebok pumps two
years ago he was sporting around here
and first time I saw him I laughed
second time I saw him I talked about him
third time I liked him takes three times
takes it you gotta be exposed to Pelle
nine three times I like that did you
ever have a pair know you've never felt
the pump never felt the palm you've
never experienced I've pumped pumping
your own feet I've pumped
other people's feet just out of
curiosity knit is one of the best
feelings I had in the 90s so do you want
these to you
where these I gotta tell you to then be
mad do you want at any minute guys they
they had two kinds of pumps they had the
cheaper pumps which just had the tongues
that would pump up and then the more
expensive pumps somehow they got the air
into the back of the shoe as well
bladder system so you felt beat you it's
like being pumped from all sides
so you're saying yes to this and I can
see you wearing pumps you should hey
find out what size allergy layers you
wear Jordans I can't wear Jordans
because that's what you do it's not get
it on the pump it's not mom don't you
wear vans I got to ask you I'm getting
some pump you here's the thing it's not
about you maybe I'll buy Alec wearing
the pumps it's about you feeling the
pump the only thing this point oh I'm
not even thinking about trends at this
point I'm just thinking about how good
the pump felt and can't believe that you
never felt it talk about shoes flops
those like soccer flops with socks I
actually have a pair of those maybe
Sambas adidas sandals where it's just
the one big three strike that goes over
the top of your foot slides there's a
lot of slides sweet um slides they don't
flop they slide you're right um I got a
pair of those you got one you got a pair
now yeah they're white with green
stripes but and I've worn them to
Ralph's a couple of times but I do not
wear them with socks I slid right I
didn't do that
alright well I sweat too much if I don't
wear socks and then if I wear socks I
slide right out what does he got Crystal
Pepsi
it's a beverage that ain't coming back I
think they tried that they didn't work
overalls I never personally owned owned
a pair I'd like three I did it's really
hard for a post toddler and I think it
came back for girls my wife my wife
wears has a pair of overalls
yeah and has had a pair and you know
what it's great it's fine it's good it's
real good well yeah it's real good what
I wasn't trying right it's also weird if
I'm like oh yeah it's real good what do
you want to say it's fine you know
you better talk more about my wife I
want some overalls that pump so revo
pump overalls I'm gonna miss my
tight-fitting jeans I want I want pants
that feel tight but then look loose oh
no where's the pump where's the bladder
everywhere mm-hmm the pumps in the strap
you don't here's the thing you don't
cinch it up you pump the strap and
that's how it cinches Reebok Pump
overalls we'll bring them back fanny
packs fanny packs are back yeah my you
may have noticed that my son wore one on
vacation on vacation in the entire time
I am
I mean it's tempting it's so utilitarian
it's so functional that this is again
when I think about the pump I think
about the feel of the pump it should
come back when I think about the fanny
pack I think about how useful it is
there's so much better I'll tell you
right now I'll do it it's gonna take me
a while and it's gonna hurt but I would
it has to be the right one it can't be -
it can't be - look at my fanny pack
colored in Westerly go it goes has to be
subtle over you goes over the shirt
right like if you got a shirt this
untucked the fanny pack is a fanny pack
on the pants or isn't on the shirt it's
up to you it's on the way Hsieh but do
you put your shirt over it because if
you if the shirt goes over the fanny
pack I'm not out I'm not in then now I
got an unexplainable bulge right it's a
fanny pack you know I don't want to
unexplainable bulge
I want explainable bulges right to me
it's like what's in it what do I need
that I would I would be happy to have on
me your phone you put here's the thing
about it putting in phone and if
anything it's you know you know like you
don't you get don't you don't get the
the ghost the ghost buzz anymore you
don't actually sit on it and mess your
back up but I want my I mean there's
also like a hiking contingent that try
that kind of brought back the fanny pack
for their purposes maybe five years ago
- contingency and their purposes so I
might there might I might get like more
of like a granola fanny pack
I don't think so we should maybe we
should sell a fanny pack we should look
into that we already talked about cross
colors but we've got champion Fela Tommy
Hilfiger Louis Vuitton Gucci just
clothing brands that were hip-hop sort
of inspired in our back because of
hip-hop they're already back we can't
even have a say in this but I don't
think it's what was hip culture is now
means hip-hop culture is now mainstream
culture so when we were kids I really
liked hip hop but I couldn't dress like
a rapper I mean yeah I didn't get on
that train in the 90s and I don't think
I'm gonna get on it now but our kids can
dress close to what rappers dress like
because it's just that's just culture
and I think that I think that's a I
think that's a good thing yeah
definitely but I don't think I'm gonna
go there in terms of it you know I I
feel like it's gonna look like I'm
trying too hard if I do that well if you
were in these name if I have a Gucci
it's pride tracksuit you even ever have
a knockoff Gucci tracksuit I think I'm
not gonna do that
something that we did take part in
especially you Ambrose in Kappa soccer
shorts I was a sucker man
so I were the sucker shorts in nightlife
just for practice I mean it would and
I'm assuming this was ubiquitous around
the country but people were Imbros it to
school it was like I'm wearing Ambrose
to school today
yeah I'm wearing these things that I
could be ready to play soccer at any
point but I'm just doing math and they
were short and wide and at Buies Creek
Elementary School which went up to 8th
grade for us this the teachers called us
all into like a student wide meeting and
they had an orientation where they said
boys if you're gonna wear these um Bros
you need to you don't need to let you
junk flop around you don't need to wear
boxers animum bros together because
literally teachers were saying that they
were catching glimpses of stuff through
the open legs of Ambrose that they
didn't they didn't
get paid enough to see right there it
was trying to teach it the counties of
North Carolina and then they got a
couple of 13 year old balls hanging out
yeah cause he legs that'll that'll
distract you but that high score tank
that was an awkward school assembly yeah
and I didn't I I didn't where I'm broke
because I was 11 feet tall you know as
like at some point you just as I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna go with that trend
remember the other school assembly where
they had to address the fact that guys
are going around and hitting each other
in the balls and mister future all had
to like explain anatomically how bad it
was to hit someone unsuspectingly in the
balls
what middle school I didn't take part in
that trend circle glasses now I you know
I'm not gonna take part in this I don't
work glasses but your glasses have
evolved over the years would you evolve
them and to just straight up circles
we're talking like like John Lennon like
well but like people yeah I know but
like Dwayne Wayne without snow the
rapper snow and Pharma know what no I
mean colored yeah they were color a
little bit I mean it'll happen
it's sunglasses that you're on board for
sunglasses changed so much that and it
so quickly that people just buy them I
buy them so I actually think that's a
way that it's an easy way for people to
feel like they're doing something cool
like normal people who've left the train
and calcified as you say they still try
to buy cool sunglasses that sunglasses
are always gonna change and you're in
and when was the last time you went
sunglass shopping and thought
everything's basically the same now is
some version of ray-bans what do you
call what you have on right now what's
the style of glasses that like good like
the 5000 out of it
it's either aviators or those or corner
in like a horn room it and it's some
version of that so the circle is just
sitting there waiting in triangles to
triangles are coming coming back okay
some entertainment double-dare is back
nobody was back I mean they got marks
some are still doing it I'm told but in
Liza Kochi when Liza coach was any we
asked her about it I have not watched it
but I'm sure she's great and more power
to them of Gladys back but you haven't
watched it so you can't I mean we can't
really evaluate it but we know we like
Liza so something I have watched full
house and now fuller house and I think
in I heard you saying this earlier and I
don't know if they talked about it or if
it's just independent my kids especially
Shepard he watches old full house reruns
oh really
all the time and he started watching
fuller house landed by himself Lando
watches fuller house by himself he has
no clue what's going how did he find it
like what do you think I think I think
Lily actually had watched some of it
because Christy said Lily I want to show
you this I watched this as a kid so it
was like a cross-generational thing
which is what they're after but then
Lando just kind of started liking it and
then he's watch it he watches it on his
own well this is actually opens up a
bigger conversation about multicam
comedies so multi guy multicam comedies
were dying the death that they deserved
to die
in my opinion but they did just like
Genco jeans they died and now they're
and now they can't come back multicam
actually continued through and because
they because they made it just under the
wire there's a resurgence than that
that's that's coming back I mean a I
mean there's there's the couple that
Netflix is actually producing multicam
comedies and I wouldn't be I wouldn't be
surprised if like YouTube premium all of
a sudden comes out with a multicam
comedy mm-hmm because our kids are
watching them I mean my ten-year-old son
your eight-year-old son
was in there by themselves it's simple
eunbi held watching though but when we
the 90s jam for us
I was not obsessed with anything in the
world of comedy more than Seinfeld oh
yeah I mean and with Curb Your
Enthusiasm coming back it's a it's
basically a version of it has come back
such a unique show that I'm so glad that
it worked at a time when I don't think
it made sense for it to work yeah but it
kind of restored my faith in humanity
but a steady that show was like the most
successful sitcom but aesthetically it's
nothing like Seinfeld humor wise it's
exactly like it aesthetically it's a
single cam witness is improved a lot of
times but yet I don't know I I just I
can't do the multicam thing I've tried
thin eyebrows so the only reason we're
talking about this is because Rihanna
was just on the cover of what was the
photo Vogue the fashion issue you know
how I feel about Rihanna I've made that
very clear
quantify it well I just haven't you know
I have a I have a soft spot for her if
you want to call it that and I'd call it
the opposite yeah I was gonna say hard
spot but then it just anyway I really
like Rihanna and I think she's very
attractive okay well really I really I
know I asked you to I'm not the best the
first thing I think about when I think
about Rihanna I think about her amazing
body of work and that's really the thing
that that's the really the thing that I
that I'm thinking about her body of work
anyway on the cover of Vogue she's got
puny brows as we called them they dip
the thin pencil painted on eyebrows I
mean they removed basically all of her
eyebrows I can't believe you did it
RiRi I really can't she still looks good
hey but big night as she could never
came all the way back what
remember that just a few years ago it
was like the big eyebrows are coming
back when you when I look back and I
love pictures of our wives during that
phase when it just got down to like it
wasn't even eyebrow anymore it was just
a hint of an eyebrow it was there was an
eyebrow here at one point just want you
to know where it was mm-hmm it's in this
general region where now I have a line
and there's ladies horrible there's many
people who got rid of everything and
then tattooed the line but I guess
that's kind of genius because then you
could just let your hair grow over it
and now that it's coming back site yes
and then I'm back yeah but a lot of
people put the tattoo the line in a
different place from where the hair was
to get a constantly surprised look so
then if you if you go on the face you're
going Matt you've got double eyebrows
you know nobody wants it it's like an
eyebrow echo I'd buy a ticket of that
you don't want you don't want that I
really hope those don't come back
eyebrow brow hair highlights on dudes so
we're talking about bleaching the hair
letting grout frosted tips instinct
action you know you're gonna have
highlights in the next I'd say I give
you I give you swells six years I kinda
think I already have a form of no
natural hair you're not very good you're
gonna do something I am a trendsetter
you're gonna do something intentional
for my I'm good
I'm I don't know what the ratio of gray
to silver to dark dark brown my hair is
going to continue to evolve but I'm glad
I made the choice and I'm sticking with
that man okay well here's something that
I think there's a much better chance
that you will legitimately do goatee you
had one before
oh yeah it'd be so easy for you to have
one again I just feel like I feel like
it's kind of it's like it's like a white
zombie thing but like if I had a goatee
now it would be salt and pepper and it
would be really long like a demon and I
would feel like I feel like I'd be more
human than you know okay think about it
I'm gonna pitch you on growing a goatee
okay and I want you to really listen to
me I want you to take this completely
sir
I'm not doing this for entertainment
purposes I want you to grow a goatee in
your own time but not too far into the
future here's why
think about the mustache right okay so
the mustache was something that
signified it signifies the 80s and
everyone who has grown a mustache in Los
Angeles and elsewhere over the past ten
years has done it 100% ironically right
like anybody who's done it in this town
has done it ironically and now there are
people who just wear a mustache and we
think that they're cool but the goatee
is is still too recent in our memory as
something that's uncool and like says
like 90s youth pastor that nobody wants
to actually have one but the next person
to grow a goatee ironically and it's
gonna be like like if if you grow a
goatee and every other part of you is
cool but you got a goatee so all the
signals that's how you know somebody
with a mustache is doing ironically yeah
all the signals from everywhere else
shoes all the way to the hair are
signaling this person understands and is
making specific intentional fashion
choices
that's a cool person that's a cool you
you could be the first you could be the
first do it bring the goatee back do you
have to also be 24 I don't think so you
call a goatee with that haircut with
this half-cut sweatshirt and I'm not
talking mister were you laughing or
crying I'm not talking I'm not talking a
long one I'm talking about as youth
pastor as you could possibly die kid I
could do that in four days I know you
have nothing to lose man oh gosh my love
life is one thing I have to lose I'm
just pitching you on the goatee I don't
feel like the goatee goes with this
ensemble I don't feel like I'm choosing
enough but I'm not making enough bold
choices with everything else in order to
okay this is your house we're sure helps
okay it'd be a lot warmer around my
mouth but the last thing I'll say is
that I feel like we're in this very
I'm maybe I'm not speaking for you
because you seem like you kind of know
exactly what you want to do I feel torn
and I feel like the 90s seem uncool to
me I don't think that they were a
distinctive period we're like cool
things were accomplished in fashion and
so every single thing that's coming back
with the exception of things that we'll
just be more comfortable because they're
baggy er I'm not excited about what I'm
going to look like and I feel like
sooner rather than later I'm gonna have
to make the choice am i pulling the
lever changing tracks and getting on
Jeff Goldblum's going to Jeff Goldblum
town should I wait until I'm 50 or
should I just should I start going there
now I don't know I am really torn
because I feel like I'm choosing between
baggy blocked colored clothes or some
sort of cool old man clothes and I don't
like either one of my choices to be
completely honest with you I'd like to
stick with tight hoodies and skinny
jeans but I know I can't do it because
it's already past I'm I'm open to
inventing a look like we were a band
like a two-person band that was of an
alternative genre and then I just want
to make sure it's comfortable I don't I
don't want to I don't want to have to
wear multiple pieces like an ensemble so
I'm game for this and the goatee you got
me I don't want to just wear like a 14
piece suit and a top hat every day
though I mean those harem pants who said
that I thought we talked about this
before this isn't this is like it your
biscuit earlier on we were talking about
how at that time it's interesting even
compare because we we had a very similar
conversation I'm interested in how we've
changed in the year or so since we
talked about it because your tongue at
the time you were telling my shaving
your head and growing a big old beard
and I have them baggy clothes yeah
that's what that's what my I want to do
in my heart
you look like a guru remember that we
were talking about that yeah I forgot
about that
I'm just fighting and now we got a
little bit more fight in us we got some
fashion fighting okay next time you see
us like I'll have a goatee I'll be
dressing like Jeff Goldblum everything's
gonna be great and we will be here again
continuing continue to let us know what
you think we should be watching on
YouTube because we are going to let you
know what we watched and what we think
is good for part two of that and let's
keep this conversation going using hash
tag ear biscuits thanks for hanging out
with us which passion train should we be
on
[Music]